نبدا من تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
حيث قالت الاداره العسكريه في مدينه
بوكوربيسك بمقاطعه دونيسك ان عدد ضحايا
القصف الروسي على المدينه ارتفع الى
ثمانيه قتله واكثر من ثلاثين جريحا وبحسب
الاداره العسكريه الاوكرانيه فان القوات
الروسيه اطلقت صاروخا من طراز اسكندر على
منطقه سكنيه وسط مدينه بوكروفيسك واتبعته
بصاروخ ثاني استهدف المنطقه عينها اثناء
اخلاء المصابين
ينضم الينا من بوكوروفيسك في مقاطعه
مازن ابراهيم الذي يتابع من عين المكان ما
الذي جرى الليله الماضيه اهلا بك معنا
نعم في الواقع عبد السلام ما حصل في هذه
المدينه هو نموذج عما يحصل في عشرات
البلدات والمدن في مقاطعه دونيتش والتي
تتعرض بشكل دائم للقصر المدفعي ولكن الذي
حصل هنا كان ماسويا دعنا نشاهد ما الذي
حصل في هذه المنطقه تحديدا في وسط مدينه
بكره في هذه المنطقه التي تعتبر منطقه
سكنيه بامتياز هذا الفندق تعرض لصاروخ في
ساعات متاخره من مساء يوم امس يمكن ان
نشاهد هذا الفندق الذي وصل اليه الصاروخ
روسي استهدفه بشكل مباشر ادى الى مقتل شخص
واصابه سبعه اخرين بجراح الذي حصل بعد
سقوط هذا الصاروخ الاول هرعت فرق الانقاذ
الى هذه المنطقه تحديدا الى هذا المربع
السكني كان هنالك فرق انقاذ مدفع عديده
حاولت الوصول وانقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه على
مستوى الجرحى والمصابين ولكن بعد نحو 20
دقيقه سقط صاروخ ثان في هذا المجمع يمكن
ان نشاهد نحن نتحدث عن مجمع مدني هنا
حديقه للاطفال
في وسط المجمع الذي وصلت اليه الصواريخ
الصاروخ هذه بعض مخلفات الصاروخ التي يقوم
بعض العاملين مع جهاز الادعاء هنا في
مقاطعه المدعي العام والجهاز التابع له
باحصاء بعض المخلفات وجمعها كي يعينوها
لان الاتهام الاوكراني يتحدث بان القوات
الروسيه استخدمت صواريخ اسكندر هذا الامر
اكدته السلطات المحليه هناك كذلك اكده
الرئيس الاوكراني سقط الصاروخ الثاني في
هذه المنطقه ضمن هذا المجمع نحن نتحدث
يمكن ان تشاهد حديقه للاطفال هنا هذا
المجمع السكني عند نحو التاسعه ونصف مساء
سقط الصاروخ الثاني مما ادى الى مقتل
مجموعه كبيره من الاشخاص واصابه اخرين
كانوا يتواجدون هنا في هذه المنطقه سواء
من عمال الانقاذ الذين كانوا يحاولون
انقاذوا المتضررين والمصابين من فندق
الاول من الصاروخ الاول الذي اصاب الفندق
او الذين يتواجدون هنا عمليا يجري الحديث
من قبل السلطات على ان حجم الماسات الذي
وقع في هذه المدينه كبير جدا
تجاوز عدد ما بين قتيل وجريح اكثر من 80
شخصا وهذه الحصيله مرشحه لارتفاع وفقه ما
يقول
العاملون في مجال الانقاذ هنا لان هنالك
اشخاص عده جراحهم خطره وهم قد مثلوا الى
المستشفيات الذي نشاهده في بوكلوفس
يماثل ما نشهده في مناطق متعدده على مستوى
كامل المقاطعه وتحديدا المنطقه التي تسيطر
عليها القوات الاوكرانيه وما تبقى من
مقاطعه نحن نتحدث عن نحو
35% من مقاطعه دنيا هي تقع تحت القوات
الاوكرانيه غالبا ما يتم قصفها بكافه
انواع الصواريخ بالامس نائبه وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني تحدثت عن انه خلال اسبوع تم رصد
اكثر من 9000 نوع من القذائف والصواريخ
والغارات تم تنفيذها خلال اسبوع اي بمعدل
غاره او قذيفه او اطلاق صاروخ خلال كل
دقيقه هذا نموذج عن ما كنا نشاهده عمال
الانقاذ يحاولون الان ازاله الركام لان
هذا المبنى من الجهه الخلفيه معرض للسقوط
كان هنالك تحذيرات من قبل كافه العاملين
في مجال الانقاذ من مغبه التقدم اكثر
باتجاه المبنى لانه قد يسقط في اي لحظه
بالاضافه الى ان البحث يجري من قبل فريق
المدعي العام عن كل ما يرتبط
تفاصيل لها علاقه بصاروخ اسكندر الذي
اتهمت القياده الاوكرانيه القوات الروسيه
بانها